mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir et je souhaite que vous passiez
avec nous un très agréable moment
vous avez certainement suivi les
précédents épisodes de la série qui
retrace la vie de marie-antoinette entre
1769 et jusqu'à sa mort et bien ce soir
nous allons voir le quatrième et dernier
épisode de cette série réalisée par guy
andré lefranc et c'est geneviève casile
qui joue le rôle de marie antoinette
quels sont les rapports entre la
médecine et le sport et plus précisément
le football
eh bien ce sera ce soir à 22h05 le thème
de l'émission médical d'igor barrère
pierre des groupes et étienne les loups
et pour participer à cette émission et
bien nous aurons la présence de l'équipe
de football de reims cette célèbre
équipe qui à part donc prêté son
concours à cette émission pour des tests
pour des études médicales et vous venez
de l'entendre c'est à 23 heures que
julien besançon nous présentera son
journal la france en 1792 la vie et les
derniers moments de marie-antoinette
c'est ce que nous allons vivre
maintenant avec la quatrième et dernière
partie de cette série
marie antoinette